foreign
[Music]
humans checking in right before right
before getting on here I'm dealing with
annoying humans uh like great appeals I
hate it when a student sends you a great
appeal and then you respond with like
four pages of explanation and then they
still send you back another response and
try to like argue with you oh I was
getting that too
it's like
I haven't been here at all for the past
four months can I like hand in my
outstanding work like oh yeah yeah no no
this is this is the part of our job that
needs to be automated yes yes the rest
of it's going to be automated uh like
regardless of our protestations but this
part if it were automated that'd be
great it's something you're just like
quote departmental policy and Senate
policy to student emails that would be
just better than me well we can't we
can't use GPT right now it's down right
yeah I have this one yeah it's been
working here and there but yeah like so
oh you're telling me that they missed
eight classes and eight tutorials and
has haven't handed in any work but
you're telling me that they've been
doing the readings yeah I think there's
definitely a sense that all the
relaxations around covid have also
affected like like there's a need to
reassert academic Integrity like all of
this deadline pushing all of the no more
doctor's note stuff like like it's just
reinforcing the business side of the
University rather than the academic side
which is just like I don't know classic
[ __ ] you're so right about that
you're so right about that that academic
integrity and actually speaking of the
chat bot
um I I was also having a discussion with
a professor about the implications of
this
and uh that this professor agrees very
much that uh that this is a game changer
and
I don't know where I think we're we're
actually planning to maybe do some sort
of meeting with the faculty in the
department to talk about
um what if anything is possible what
like my prediction I think I said this
to the uh this professor and also an
administrative person that we were we
had an email Thread about this
and I my prediction is basically that I
think by the time September Comes Around
a majority of undergrad students will
realize the capabilities of this and
will chew various degrees
be taking advantage of this technology
yeah complete their assignments oh like
some of the Integrity issues are
definitely around showing up this is not
a distance education institution this is
not a place where it's like oh I missed
that assignment like can I just have a
redo it's like
the further that gets pushed the the
harder it's going to be to come back to
that and be like universities are
respectable institutions with high
standards versus like yeah we'll do
whatever you want just get yourself
standards are being questioned both by
covid and then now this AI I feel like
this whole idea of academic standards
aren't being called into question yeah
that's a good tie-in yeah sorry pills I
interrupted you
well the benefit will be that you don't
have to read any of those you know the
the fail papers that are like completely
unreadable not even failed papers like C
papers that are like unreadable but you
still figure out what they're trying to
say yeah that there will be no excuse
for those anymore so that'll that'll be
that'll be nice
I was I was thinking about that but I
know those exact papers where you almost
feel like you're some kind of like uh
you're like trying to like
um what's sift through the sand for like
sensible Concepts yeah okay I think I
think I understand what they're saying
they used a thesaurus but use the words
wrong yeah yeah exactly or they say like
I will they make like weird absurd
strong statements like I will prove I
love it when students use I will prove
yeah it's just like you can like sorry
and social sciences there's no such
thing as proving anything like you can
argue you can offer evidence absolutely
you're in one you're in like a hundred
level of course yeah you're not gonna
prove you're not gonna be proving
anything here sorry yeah exactly exactly
plausibility is the best you can hope
for anyway last week and I some of the
feedback I got from the episode last
week talking about education
um they seem to think that we're
overrating the value of this thing and I
want to very well now we're going to do
the flip side today because I think that
calling any this anything even remotely
near Consciousness is very stupid but I
want to specify the only thing we were
talking about is our
our busy work at a at education
institutions where everything is
prescribed and you're basically
following a formula and anyway and you
write you know passably vanilla
papers that just string words together
they don't necessarily even demonstrate
that you have any intelligence or
intelligent thought behind it you're
just handing it into complete an
assignment that specifically very
specifically and narrowly is what this
AI is going to entirely overturn but if
you think that this is the singularity
or some [ __ ] like that we are gonna
we're gonna dissuade you of that notion
did some people think that we thought
that this computer was approaching
Consciousness because I feel like no no
no I don't think anyone said that I
think they just said you're overrating
like how good this actually is it's kind
of stupid but in our defense students
are kind of stupid almost yes that's
that's exactly the point yeah that's
exactly
we write could be automated definitely
yes like we were talking about earlier
if it could just cite policy recognize
key phrases and cite the court rep look
the appropriate passages like of
whatever the syllabus right like so many
questions I'm just like read the damn
syllabus and like all the answers are
there it's really just a very good kind
of stupid form of intelligence which is
most of our life our most of a human
life is kind of stupid intelligence okay
exactly and I think I I think I I
thought I stressed this in the last
episode because I think at the time I
was responding to something a professor
tweeted about how like some other
Twitter thread that was like this is
overrated and and if you think that this
is gonna like write good papers and you
don't know what a good paper writing is
and it's like no no you're missing the
point like the point is a vast majority
of undergrad papers are not good they're
not good writing and this is going to do
a much better job at writing not good
things way better than right now and
like that's the problem yeah I think
we're we're so close to the whole
process no one expects them to be good
right no one expects an undergraduate
paper to be exactly you expect it to be
passable and that's it that's the point
of it we're so close to this whole
process that we just see potential
procedural things that maybe alter heard
by this smart technology but I mean fair
fair enough we were maybe indulging in a
little bit of paranoid speculation based
on like how this may impact our jobs
which is obviously extremely indulgent
and yeah yeah like I mean I hope maybe
today we can maybe move this towards a
more theoretical
ground to you know like the bread and
butter of what critical theory and
philosophy right like trying to frame
something with with
a theoretical approach and talking about
the schools of thought that are
interested in this sort of topic one of
them of course you can bring along your
Marxism your post-modernism your
post-humanism
and other you know other frames of
reference in critical theory and yeah
today we're probably going to talk a
little bit about the transhumanist oh I
don't know if you could call it a wing
of post-humanism or transhumanism as
just my theory being that it's just a uh
kind of a stem-centered wet dream a kind
of ideology of engineering yeah I mean I
think that this you know these recent
developments
to me actually get us no closer to like
some kind of singularity in my opinion
they don't like it's just really cool
algorithms that can do really cool
things but but I don't I don't see us
and I guess we'll have to Define uh
because there's a couple different
senses of that word Singularity but in
on the computational end yeah I mean I I
don't think there's and I don't think
this has any any philosophical
implications about like AI Consciousness
or AI self-awareness or any of that
stuff it's just like a really cool way
it's a really basically it's just a
really cool system of pattern
recognition in language yeah that's able
to be like to to be somewhat predictive
based on that pattern recognition like
that's all yeah I kind of thought of it
afterwards as it's an information
management tool that's all it is if you
look at the world as a giant library of
information this is just a really
effective tool for calling up storing
retrieving and kind of whatever mashing
up montaging that information that's all
it is it doesn't generate anything new
you know it doesn't it just manages
what's already there it yeah like this
people kind of have that instinct
[ __ ] and [ __ ] out right precise
on what we do with it in the end and I
mean but it is fun this time because it
does kind of touch on you know a
singularity event must have happened in
the history of the Matrix movie or uh
the the host of other movies that
feature a self-intelligent self-aware
technology like uh I don't know what's
that like that Avengers one Age of
Ultron there's there's a whole shitload
of them this Terminator Will Smith
movies I think maybe more than one
Skynet
Skynet became self-aware at whatever
date it was I can't do it Arnold
Schwarzenegger accent yeah this guy
never became self-aware on whatever
September 29th 1997 and whatever yeah
this dystopic imaginations are ran away
with us but we're aware of that I think
that's that's it's okay to indulge in
every now and then
well we have a few terms to get through
and to maybe Define so AI plus
transhumanism plus Singularity I guess
you could just call this Silicon Valley
philosophy because Silicon Valley
philosophy a lot of these um a lot of
the tech companies have their in-house
philosophers which I find very funny the
the hyper real philosophers and a lot of
what they say today we read Kurzweil by
the way
um but a lot of what is called
philosophy is just like people
speculating on completely untestable
future scenarios and they are allowed to
call that Philosophy for some reason so
I found that I found that yeah this is a
lot like what like what's her name Atlas
Shrugged and those sort of things
they love animals they're so dumb this
is like an evolution of anarandianism
into a weird like techno dystopia
dystopia line of thinking that's that's
what they also have a new utilitarian
ethics that they are branding I forget
what it's called but they have a
utilitarian ethics they also value
stoicism of course like anything that
allows them to be more indifferent to
the world in general again like ethics
acting as a self-justification not so
different from what you would find in
any kind of like bioethics course that
tries to teach you know like read a
textbook about bioethics and and medical
procedures or something right it's kind
of a self-justification ethics and so
that's all it really is in the end it's
it's again it's my Theory it's all a
kind of a stem wet dream a kind of stem
ideology fetishistic ideology well wait
what is so like let's just
um get clear on what we're talking about
here are you just saying like
the chatbot itself or I think the the I
guess the singularity Style Oh The
Singularity yeah that maybe
is gets evoked when we start ringing the
alarms about AI advancements and these
sorts of things these new things that
take us yeah like Singularity right so
that's the term that means um the it is
we've already said it it's the moment
where AI becomes like switches on
becomes true becomes self-aware and some
people use that term as the
technological singularity and then I
don't sorry I don't think it's uh
awareness it's the moment when it be it
becomes able to improve itself without
yeah yeah like write its own code kind
of thing figure out things figure out
things on its own yeah I don't know that
self-awareness is anything yeah it's
true it's true having having like a
qualia and experience doesn't
necessarily need to be the case for the
singularity I guess simulating what we
would call self-awareness as in like the
Chinese room or something like that or
even or even like if you give it
um some kind of objective
where it can somehow fulfill and
reinterpret its own objective in some
unexpected way
would maybe be like a sign towards the
singularity right where it has some kind
of some kind of like its algorithms are
built in a way where it'll end up giving
us you know like I remember one of the
hypotheses would be that maybe we would
get to a point where we would have such
an advanced computer
um kind of intelligence that it would
figure out
solutions to problems we have in the
world in ways that we never expected
like I don't know they might cure cancer
based on the information they have
because they they're so much better
Advanced not because they're conscious
but just because the system itself is so
Advanced that it's able to to
reinterpret and and and re-jigger its
own kind of objective and programming in
a way that that lets it spit out really
really Advanced solutions to problems
like with the go the go game oh yeah the
Go game yeah go yeah that is that that
sort of checkers-like game
well it's a super complicated triggers
are supposed to be able to be good yeah
and it's supposed to be like this form
of art but a the the the machine
learning uh thing that whatever it is
the it's not enough deep learning it's a
neural net the neural net that beat the
best go player in the world it wasn't
designed to play go it wasn't it was
like designed as a general learning
thing so it just basically you apply it
to any game I think it played DOTA which
is a video game also
um but you just make it play over and
over and over again because it's a
computer it can play like a million
games per hour or whatever it is and
then it begins to recognize patterns
that people could never play so it's
kind of like a generalized sort of
intelligence applied to one specific
thing yeah I mean I remember the
consolation prize in that match was that
the the player the human player made
this like really good move that sent the
AI on a bit of a loop before it could
beat him and that and that was like
trumpeted as this major like Victory
like I called it consolation prize
because the AI still won but it was like
trumpeted out as this kind of victory of
human intelligence still it's kind of
funny to think about when I remember it
must have been what like eight years ago
or something when they had that computer
program go on Jeopardy
um whatever that was called and I feel
like it's kind of funny how at the time
people were impressed by that but this
this thing we have now is probably like
that you we all just have access to I
think I don't know if I actually tested
it but I did ask it one time I was like
can you answer Jeopardy questions and it
was like oh yeah no problem
it's good it's good at language but I I
think there's another point to this uh
the alphago thing that people recognize
a little bit or don't recognize
is that it kind of also speaks to how
good human intelligence is because even
the person who plays go professionally
has probably played a very small
fraction of how many games the AI has
played but because of physical
limitations you can't we can't practice
that much
um what's also interesting similar with
the uh with DOTA DOTA is a is a MOBA
video game and it beat the best player
in the world
um and again it's not it doesn't break
any of the rules of the game it learns
by playing but it can play so much so
fast that human intelligence is actually
in some way Superior I mean in a lot of
ways superior but in Superior in that we
can learn more by doing it fewer times I
think yeah yeah and thinking with like
analogy and creatively and symbolically
is in a way that computers can't but I
mean it does fate it does to a degree
forces to confront maybe like our
Romanticism about like human
intelligence as well that there are
things that are off limits to artificial
intelligence or or information retrieval
Technologies or some kind of like
there's just areas that are like sacred
right like it's like Marx's thing right
everything sacred will be profaned and
we have to confront a bit of the like
lingering Romanticism about
how unique humans are in the universe
which is a good maybe a good
post-humanist point but I think I think
the the transhumanists take that to like
the umph degree and
speculate about you know first the AI
Singularity that's the one and then the
other way Singularity is often used is
is the moment we achieve immortality
we're able to through whatever medical
Technologies stem cells regeneration
whatever we able to Children's blood
yeah like this article started out like
I'm one of the the one of the older Baby
Boomers and now our generation has this
like hope that maybe in our lifetime
we'll be able to achieve Immortal
immortality like long lasting infinitely
prolonged life which would be again the
moment of that achievement is like a
biological Singularity I guess as well
which is a little bit a field from AI
but like Consciousness uploading and AI
or kind of beside that yeah I mean the
only thing the only part of it that's
kind of related is really just that
question of of like uploading and
computer human interface
but the rest of it like that medical
technology right like Oregon you know um
growing and all those other things I
mean that's really a biomedical question
that doesn't really have like
particularly with artificial
intelligence yeah like physical
immortality in our bodies versus the
moment where AI becomes able to
creatively write its own code without
being based on previous human
programming or something like there's
two different ways of looking at it so
we're looking at the the technological
AI
which is like
Ultron when when do we get Ultron
I think you are too Eric but I am a
post-humanist
and I've said that before um it's one of
the few things I can identify with
without qualifications but I am a
post-humanist and also an
anti-transhumanist so could could you
define could you define post-humanism
again
no I mean it's so hard because there's a
lot of things it's a lot of different
identifies of it so what part of which
aspect of it do you identify with well
there's actually several versions of
post-humanism I think uh Eric well
here's another way to ask the question
Eric tends a little bit more towards the
ecological post-humanism and I tend more
towards the technological post-humanism
but the easiest way to define it is to
say something like we were never human
to begin with
okay because uh yeah well the the other
way of asking the question
that I was that occurred to me was
is it more something that you're against
rather than something that you're for
yeah I mean I'm I think I'm for certain
things yeah that really like your your
adoption of the position of
post-humanism is more like uh because of
a family of views in society that you
don't like and and then that puts you in
the post-humanism camp
um I just think it's the most
descriptively true it's not the world I
prefer even it's just the most
descriptively true okay so with respect
to Consciousness for example
um Consciousness very very complicated
term
um to me it has a lot to do with
phenomenology especially as expressed by
Maurice marluponti
um but outside of that con like asking
will a computer ever be conscious my I
I'm pretty hard no same but my answer
that it's hard no is also to qualify
that by saying but also most humans are
not conscious almost all of the time
yeah that so that's a qualification of
Consciousness saying well when we when
we speak about that term it doesn't
really apply to people either except
sometimes which is to say something like
Consciousness is not something that you
have or possess it's not a property it's
like a quality of certain actions yeah I
haven't delved like see this problem I
haven't delved very deeply into the
philosophy of Mind debates like
cognitive science and like the
philosophers that are really paying
attention to that area which which
covers a lot of there's a lot of overlap
with like analytic philosophy cognitive
science philosophy of mind and those
sorts of approaches so like I tend to
just stay away from talking about
Consciousness at all like it's it
doesn't pass the what like the second
grade of clarity test right like ideas
have to be clear and the ideas have to
be distinct I.E they have to have like
an abstract definition that we all agree
on and Consciousness is not that it's
like a thing we think we're familiar
with it we think we know it when we see
it but we can't Define it and it
it's well we're gonna we're gonna have a
big question mark it's a big huge
question mark right I don't know yeah
the phenomenological approaches is
probably the most
congenial although post-humanists do
have problems with phenomenology so like
it's good it's not anything let's get
the yeah let's get the ai's definition
of Consciousness what do you think we're
gonna have to Define it even though or
can't fully Define it of course but you
know within the context of an hour and
15 Minute Podcast we can come up with
some sort of definition what does the AI
say the AI says Consciousness is the
state of being aware of one's thoughts
feelings and surroundings it is the
quality or state of being conscious or
having an awareness of One's Own
existence and the external world it is
the ability to experience and perceive
the external world as well as to think
and reason in short Consciousness is the
quality or state of being aware of One's
Own thoughts and feelings as well as the
external world that word repetitive
statement yeah it is that we're just
though it kicks the can down the road
because it says it's awareness of
thoughts and feelings but what is
awareness because the awareness part is
the conscious part yeah uh right how do
you define it how do you define
awareness because everything has
awareness forget mushrooms have
awareness
Yeah well yeah I could try to I could
try to ask it don't use the word
awareness in your in your in your
definition okay yeah it does well I mean
you get into the diridian problem right
where it's like every word in the
definition is going to refer to other
words add infinitum like you'll get to
that point
and then sort of realize okay like
when we go back and formulate our
approach to this you can you can map it
into traditions of thinking right so
like the Consciousness approach of of
that Kant opened up right like the unity
of app reception like the unity of the
ego that's that's what you know that's
the way to approach Consciousness
philosophically is to take a position
for or against like the kantian kind of
you're either an anti-contian
and you're totally against any talk of a
transcendental subject or you adopt some
modification of The kantian View
which is all right I got a new
definition okay
so here it says Consciousness is the
state of being able to perceive think
and feel
it is the subjective experience of being
alive and having a sense of self
it is the ability to have subjective
experiences and introspection and to be
able to control one's actions and
behavior look it did the same thing now
it just replaced awareness with what
perception
introspection and a subjective
experience so that doesn't do anything
to define consciousness because now we
just have to define those things and
also differentiate how they don't apply
to mushrooms but if you want if you want
if I can just apply this back to what I
said about post-humanism as we were
never humans in the first place all of
these words that the AI is using and
that others use to describe
Consciousness are these terms like
reflection self-reflection introspection
so you're thinking about yourself and
immediately then if you're thinking
about yourself there's a question of how
you think and always this runs up again
is the problem of language because
usually your thoughts about yourself
like am I thinking this is a linguistic
phenomenon
and the linguistic phenomenon is now no
longer self reflection because you
didn't invent your language you came in
to a system of language so immediately
when you say now oh no we are thinking
about our subjective experience
as soon as language becomes a part of
that mix and I can't imagine any way
that language does not become a part of
that mix then the subjective nature of
it is Tainted because language is not
something that is subjective solely it's
something that is outside so all the
words as soon as you say okay now we
have to figure out this word now we have
to figure out the next word the the self
that it's supposed to be conscious at
the center of this whole apparatus it's
we could say polluted there is no pure
subjectivity but everything about
Consciousness is supposed to be
dependent on and reflecting upon this
subjectivity
though though in any case the thing that
I think these definitions are are
missing a little bit that I would like
to add if we're trying to figure out
what it is is that there's a background
implicit question of why behind
Consciousness or should I should just
say unconscious actions conscious
actions are an answer to an implied
question of why
I think my little touring test then for
if something has Consciousness would be
uh can they experience boredom boredom
which might be related to having a sense
of self like it might be the case that
it's impossible to be bored if you don't
have a sense of self
and also implied I mean I say that
because implied in boredom is there's a
why like why why do I think why am I why
do I do what I do exactly rather than
just doing things so I don't think
animals get bored
um I'm willing to face some criticism
from that if people disagree dogs seem
to get kind of bored I was just gonna
say dogs seem like they're bored because
they hassle you they want to do more
things they want to engage they want to
connect true true but I think the
difference that I would draw there a lot
of things want to engage in Connect uh
proteins want to engage and connect but
there's a difference in sitting in a
state and understanding I'm in a state
of boredom and this will solve it as
opposed to just doing things I mean I
I'm not going to go deeply into this but
I mean the animal studies folks have
definitely confirmed that animals do
have
something we've been denying them right
like they evoke a kind of richness in
the Wilds they evoke a very reduced kind
of mental life when they're in captivity
you know the range of signs that monkeys
can use is much higher when they're in
the wild and versus when they're being
in a lab tested or like you know raised
in a human-built environment you know
sociality and things like that like we
have to think Consciousness if it's real
it's already done work in the world
right and a lot of what we take for
granted is going to be related to that
so it's a it's a historical question in
many ways right and philosophy has
always been concerned with what is mind
what is consciousness what is thought so
it's not like we're just gonna have this
new oh transhumanism post-humanism
they're they're here to solve the
problem finally no no no these problems
are just like
fundamental Grist for what's interesting
about doing philosophy just gonna say
what you're making me think of actually
is and I I need to investigate this for
further but
um it strikes me that there could be
some overlap uh between kind of the more
Continental uh post-humanism View and
then there's like the very analytic
philosophers who my buddy who's a like
kind of a YouTubes in the streamer
political commentary World mouthy
Infidel he's like loves this view in the
analytic philosophy I think it's called
a limited eliminativism or like where
you just basically deny that
Consciousness exists you deny that
qualia is a real thing and you just say
that there are processes in our
interactions that happen
um but I don't know I'd have to
obviously investigate more but it just
sounds like there might be some some
overlap uh kind of like there's overlap
between like Donald Davidson and dareda
maybe there's some overlap between like
post-humanism and like this eliminative
eliminative [ __ ] that word is [ __ ]
impossible materialism I think yeah like
yeah it's just an Epi phenomenon of
systems of interacting particles exactly
exactly that is
it yeah yeah they're they're yeah that's
right it's uh it's uh that deflationary
view yeah right which is like
characteristic it's a kind of idealism I
guess behind the staunchly materialistic
front it puts on there's a deep-seated
idealism in that stance
but it's like yeah I mean yeah if you're
a monistic materialist even like a
spinosist you might hold that view in in
some way shape or form I mean again it's
always like it's like we just have this
concept of Consciousness it's like oh we
need to Define it and then it's solved
I don't know it's it's something I just
tend to avoid
well this is why I'm defi I'm opposed
humanist with respect to almost every
other thing you could say that is unique
about humans whether it's sign usage or
creativity or anything like that'll go
well there's plenty of stuff that does
that but the why question
not that the why even has an answer of
course it doesn't we spend our our
nights uh unable to sleep starting at
the ceiling thinking about it but I
don't think any animal
wonders why they are and we do but only
we do
very rarely very rarely some of the time
but I think this recession like the
entrance of the question into the
phenomenological Horizon uh I don't
think computers will overdo it and I
don't think that uh animals do it either
yeah I remember the best the best
depiction
of AI in like uh a movie
was in the movie uh ex machina I think
that was a great one and what I liked
about that was that you could tell that
some of the
hypothetical Androids were taking were
taking seriously well I think
Wittgenstein was kind of more of an
influence but also there was
implications of like the importance of
embodiment
um also the importance of desire for
Consciousness and that's something that
I've always thought was interesting I
remember even being an undergrad and
arguing with people about AI
and I was just like why like so I I if
you accept the conclusion that maybe a
computer could be self-aware I know
that's not obvious at all and weird but
if you accept that
then to me the question arises with okay
so it's self-aware why would it do
anything why would it care doesn't it
like desire
is I think fundamental to some kind of
um to action to like doing something and
it's like you so just because something
is aware and has like a sense of well I
mean that's a complicated question but
self-ness must be somehow tied to desire
but the point is I just think that
what I liked about that movie at least
is just the way that it made a
hypothetical artificial intelligence
it only made sense because it had desire
I think at one point in the movie he
even describes it as sexuality
um or something like that which I to me
just implied a form of like desire and
embodiment
um and those two things I think seem
like crucial aspects for anything that
would resemble
uh a human experience yeah kind of
immediately weaponized all that to
achieve Freedom yeah I think that
exactly that that's a one of the best uh
depictions but the one thing that I
think maybe was missing is like for our
or at least the way we see desire or
have desire even or our desire is
inextricably linked to uh the fact that
we're mortal and going to die so like
time is limited so what you do matter
this is a Heidegger's being towards
death
in case anyone wants to wonder where I'm
getting it from but I wonder why that
machine why that machine would want
freedom
um without death because presumably she
could also just sit in that room for
eternity and it wouldn't make any
difference to her if she's uh not a
biologically degrading organism yeah
maybe I mean I do think that you're
right I think that could have been a
nice addition but I also think it's
plausible to imagine
uh that an Android a hypothetical
Android in that situation with desire
would also feel the possibility of death
because of the Creator who it's revealed
later in the movie went through a bunch
of iterations of the Android right and
then deactivated them
um but yeah I mean I'm not here to play
apologetics for that movie it's
obviously not perfect well I I mean that
as a not a criticism of the movie either
just a general question of like why
would even if a machine had what's you
know called a general General yeah then
why would it care about anything it's
true it's true I mean that is actually
exemplified even in Heidegger's concept
of care which is I think often
misunderstood but really it just means
like the significance uh which is
related to its being towards death which
which for Heidegger is obviously
fundamental to
all of that
yeah being towards death is what makes
us care have care I mean one of the ways
one of the reasons that the question is
important is is again for like ethical
reasons though right if something has
Consciousness then we need to extend
some kind of Ethics towards it or or put
it in some kind of ethical framework
that is and share the space with our
ourselves and human beings right like
people talk if covet is conscious
according to these crazy deep ecologists
like then we shouldn't kill it we should
let it swipe this let it wipe us out or
if animals are conscious we shouldn't
use them for food now if robots are
conscious right we have to we can't
treat them like um like slave chattel
right like it comes back to those sorts
of ethical questions and that's that's
what makes it important it's like
I remember what Matt was saying on the
on our 100th anniversary episode right
like getting into philosophy because
you're like you mean 100th episode sorry
we haven't been around for 100 years 100
or 100 we we've passed the singularity
already and now it's like abstract
philosophical puzzles versus you know
getting into philosophy because there's
like real pressing questions that need
addressing at every moment in history at
every turn
and that those two sorts of like you
know the analytic philosophers tend
towards the conceptual puzzles what is
consciousness for us it's like why the
[ __ ] is it important that we Define that
other than
kind of ethical and political questions
that might arise from it that's what
makes it important
not the abstract definitional question
anyway well we are important to
ourselves goes without saying and you
don't need Consciousness to do that but
I wanted to ask you what you thought
about this track these transhumanists
this is like Silicon Valley philosophy
uh part of it it goes It goes with it
but there they seem to be very obsessed
with their mortality a lot of them
happen to be billionaires so I think
that probably has something to do with
it when you just when you have
an amount of money that you can't
possibly spend in one lifetime than the
natural next thought is to go okay how
can I live past this lifetime
um and they're doing some crazy [ __ ]
trying to figure that out but that that
is a a very important point of this
Singularity well not I I shouldn't say
the singularity
um thing because that's supposed to be
separate but they're very excited about
the development of technology in a way
that prevents their own their own deaths
I I don't I don't this obsession with
living forever
um
yeah part of me gets it but another part
of me thinks it's kind of silly well I
brought this up because we read the
Kurzweil article so yeah the link will
be in there he has conceptions about
death and no matter what you want to say
about Kurzweil uh he's a [ __ ] genius
um I know it's it every single
philosophy Prof I've ever had shits on
him because he's called a philosopher
uh he's not a philosopher I don't I
would not call him that but he's at
least a futurist and a [ __ ] genius
why do you say that or is that sarcasm
no no no no he wrote he wrote his first
computer program at the age of 14.
when there were homology when there were
only 10 computers in the state of New
York so
but this is what happens when people are
really good at something
it's not inaccurate to call uh Ray
Kurzweil a dumbass while he was writing
but I did want to say
outside of outside of his quote unquote
philosophy very good at [ __ ] yeah well
the reason I consider this all to be
kind of stem fantasy ideology whatever
Silicone Valley ideology is because one
you know the post-humanist critique of
anthropocetrism right so when you you
get you read this article about
overcoming the limits of death
um and you just get the sense yeah like
this is anthropocentric because it's the
question isn't you know ethical or
political how do we treat you know like
what are the implications of living
forever it's like what can we get what's
what is in this for us that's always the
question at the bottom of it is like
what's in it for us you know Immortal
Life good I'm on board I'm a
transhumanist now I'm gonna go into stem
and help this along okay great then okay
so I mean that's the if you accept the
frame that there's been a de-centering
of the subject and it's kind of
authoritative in philosophy right
whatever
angle you come at it you could come at
it through like content Hegel and Lacon
and look at subjectivity that way or you
can jump on board with like the more
post-humanist side of things
and post-modern views of and and see the
subject is decentered
in that way whatever way you want to see
it like transhumanism just goes back to
a kind of naively realistic liberal
humanism
that ultimately ends with the triumphant
disembodiment of the human subjects
the no longer
being held back by the Fetters of our
biological existence right and it's
always our and we and human is always
just
the subject of everything that's written
in transhumanism
so I mean that's
the in but when you're reading it the
individual questions are so cool look at
these things stem cell regeneration
I don't know what else whatever other
kinds of Technologies they might
be waiting for to come along to help
this process along like neural hookup
Network stuff like whatever Elon Musk
has got going on right now
but those questions again are always
always anthropocentric they never
they never take
you know again real philosophy right
they never they don't take it seriously
they're just like we're doing our own
thing here
we're we're mythologizing AI that's what
it is also there's no purpose to the
project except immortality it's
immortality period like normally you
would I would think if you were
conscious maybe if you're conscious
you'd wonder why do I want to live to
get forever what do I want to do with my
time and all the all these questions and
I wonder I wonder what would happen to a
human mind if like just suppose for a
second that it could be converted to to
Binary and uploaded or whatever
your first
your first year in the in the machine
would be probably pretty cool you
wouldn't be bored yet you could do all
these different things on a different uh
substrate maybe a lot faster but then
what happens after your life for 20
years in the machine or or 50 years or a
hundred years or a thousand years in the
machine I think everyone's just going to
commit suicide if even if that were
possible it wouldn't take long I don't
think it would take 20 years for me
being in a machine before I wanted to
commit suicide like you could even ask
the question about you know when we did
our episode on personal identity and
like continuity of Consciousness it's
like you could even do that in a single
person if you're able to even just buy a
lot not through being uploaded just
keeping someone alive biologically
forever right like at what point are
they are they the same person through
that whole existence and so then are you
really living forever if you you need
like some kind of crazy Perfect Memory I
think Derek parfit in that article we
when we went heavily into that analytic
dive there like he he had this
consideration of like the continuity of
Consciousness and personal identity in
hypothetical beings that could live
forever and he he actually used that as
one of his star Trekkie kinds of uh
thought experiments to frame the
question of personal identity and memory
all beginning with kind of John Locke's
dictums about personal identity and
those questions like transhumanists are
just not interested in that because it's
just a big [ __ ] PR campaign for
engineering and like a nanotechnology
that's what it is that's the what the
ideology is concealing is it's just
apologetics for the technology industry
it's not real thought can I can I ask a
question here about
post-humanism and humanism
because I think I still find myself
just like not really understanding the
perspective but I guess just from an
outsider perspective it seems to me
there's
kind of two ways in which you could take
up humanism versus transhumanism and
there's one which is kind of like a
moral humanism or a moral post-humanism
where yeah like there's a kind of
ethical there's something ethically
problematic about looking at everything
from an anthropocentric view that like
puts the human first it's like yeah I'm
on board with that but then there's kind
of like an epistemological there's
probably more but I guess there's an
epistemological one which is like we are
just everything that we interpret in the
world is through a human perspective and
that's unavoidable because we are human
beings unless I guess you just wanted to
deny the existence of human beings
but since our perceptual capacities our
phenomenological embodied capacities
are human insofar as that term points to
an organism
then I don't understand how you could be
an epistemological post-human you know
that that takes place in the context of
confrontations again in on the grounds
of post-modernism and post-modern
culture between you know a Marxist
perspective coming from like Alpha Sarah
and Friedrich Jameson big 20th century
marxists and then the new strains of
post-structuralist post-modern thinking
that that don't like totalizing views
and emphasize particularity
yeah and the fundamental fragmentariness
you can't think the total totality so
there's certain you know a theoretical
confrontation there that has to take
place so you know de-centering of the
human subject on the side of
post-modernism let's just collectively
call at all that on the post-humanist
post-modernism their their de-centering
of the subject is yeah kind of what
you're asking questions about
whereas the marxists worry about that is
it blocks solidarity
just to put it in an extremely crude way
you know yeah yeah it blocks the coming
like we we have a historical being as
human subjects interpolated whatever you
want to call it in this and if we
disavow that
as post-humanists seem to do then we
block a kind of really important
political perspective coming from the
Marxist side
so I don't I don't think that answers
the question but the reason post
post-modernist post-humanists want to
get away from
anthropocentrism is is
because
what you're describing kind of yeah no I
get that I think but then it brings up
the problems you're asking about is like
okay we can't like what's Jane Bennett's
answer in vibrant material in the
vibrant material book she wrote um you
know in order to get away from
antipocentrism we have to cultivate
anthropomorphism more consciously more
more deliberately cultivate
anthropomorphism because yeah we can
only think things Kanti in perspective
right we can only think things according
to the structures of Consciousness that
are present everything's already
interpreted for us in a certain way as
we begin thinking yeah we have to think
through that right and I don't know if
you're a realist maybe there's some
independent non-human reality out there
if you're an idealist you don't believe
that and you yeah for sure I mean I mean
really what I had in mind is just
sometimes it feels like this the
post-humanism is sold on kind of moral
grounds or like pull it like in this
sense of being against anthropocentrism
and I guess intuitively to me it just
doesn't seem to be the case that you
have to be an epistemological
post-humanist
um
in order to accept the critiques of
anthropocentrism like I feel like you
would still be like yeah we're coming at
everything from a human perspective
that's unavoidable like that's how our
uh kind of like the ontology of like
everything is you know unavoidably we're
trapped in the in in the cage of our
Humanity well at the same time being
like that also leads to all these biases
and problems that can that can lead to
under-appreciation or under or like
abuse of the planet and all these things
and I feel like though you can hold
those two things
at the same time do you know me to be a
moralist Victor
no no I don't think that you're a
moralist I'm not saying that that's why
you but but I feel like sometimes that
it's sold it like I feel like in general
when I hear post-humanism sold it's
often in that frame yeah that's those
[ __ ] animal studies people you know
it's I mean it's not a hill I'm willing
to die on if it's gonna alienate all of
all like a whole host of left-wing
theory that should be explored further
yeah I think more and more lately as
I've been writing my dissertation I find
myself
realizing
how much my kind of
like agreement
with a philosophical School sort of
stops at psychoanalysis and
phenomenology and once we start to go
into the post-structuralism
post-modernist
it's it stops being convincing to me
even though they say a lot of
interesting things which is already
achieved a kind of de-centering of the
subject right we are conditioned by our
historical circumstances thus
unconscious we're conditioned by
language or condition even post-dar and
all that stuff habit Evolution yeah
exactly like they've already done that
like we don't need to go I mean we
always need to go back to that terrain
and and keep working it over and it's in
a way we don't need to like wash all
that away and start again with a kind of
post-humanist radical
anti-anthropocentrism that's exactly why
I don't know that's exactly why I
stopped there because I think we've
already that already decenters the
subject enough to me it's like and then
yeah I mean well that's I mean that just
all circles back to like reading
transhumanist stuff yeah they're
anthropocentric but I think from maybe a
more Marxist perspective they are
idealistic too they have no sense of
historical embeddedness of their own
points of view they don't attempt to
historicize themselves they just take it
like they're describing reality in an
unfiltered privileged kind of way
and who are their main philosophers
so there was so we mentioned did we
mention anyone's I mean we mentioned
Kurzweil who's really a futurist
um there's Peter Thiel Bostrom as well
you think Peter Tail's a philosopher no
no I don't think he's a philosopher I
don't think he's a philosopher that's
just mold bug yes that's uh that's
actually what Curtis yarvin yeah these
these uh trans humanists there's a Venn
diagram overlap with just weird
I also noticed that Renee Gerard is
becoming very popular in these circles
yeah because they're [ __ ] Trad weirdo
Catholic that's probably why
but Rene Gerard says some really
interesting cool things about my mises
like um I think I mean I remember kind
of reading a little bit oh they're
reading like mimetic in terms of medic
desire yeah
damn like so there's this guy who
recently has been popularizing
uh Rene Gerard's ideas and he's actually
a distant cousin of Ben Burgess Luke
Burgess
uh wrote a book called wanting the power
of memetic desire in everyday life and
he I think hung around with like Peter
Thiel and all these people and they all
loved this
this idea of like the kind of it's the
kind of self-help potential
of Renee Gerard's idea of memetic Desire
so it doesn't actually have that much to
do with computers and AI oh but for for
whatever reason these ideas are popular
in that Silicon Valley World partly
because Peter Thiel
got really interested in Renee Gerard
yeah I wonder what that mimesis
imitation kind of part refers to
I mean what's what's mimicking what
what's what's miming what I don't know
well I'll ask the AI to give us a
summary
so there's a few there's a few character
why you're looking up the AI there's a
few characteristics of like overlap of
this um
I don't know what we call it Silicon
Valley transhumanism like they're incr
this is a you probably picked this up
from the article but kurzweil's
incredibly optimistic
um still holds to this day I I read
something else that he wrote a little
more recently this is a little bit older
but he just thinks the world has only
gotten better is only getting better his
books are full of graphs of like poverty
being eradicated computer processing is
getting better it's uh it hit me as a
bit of a shock because I feel the
opposite I feel like we're we're getting
Dumber we're getting less conscious if
you want to bring it back to that but
he's just totally stoked like the end of
this article ends with um we stand here
at the Gateway of a new millennium with
the oh my god with the light of the
singularity already a faint glimmer on a
distant Horizon what a truly wonderful
time to be alive what an amazing series
of challenge challenges lie ahead for
humankind along with a remarkable series
of opportunities in closing I we I wish
want I wish want to express that's not a
typo I mean it is a typo but I'm not
misreading I wish want to express my
most fervent desire that each of us be
granted the basic immortality wish
simply to be given the gift of one more
day every day
so of course we we will live forever in
the glowing light of the singularity
this is a completely religious concept
by the way like there's no there's no
evidence for it there's they speak of it
as an as an inevitability and I think a
lot of us actually
um uncritically think of it as
inevitability
examine your own teleological points of
view no but this is not an inevitability
at all first of all and I am a proponent
of if I think this Singularity happens
it's going to be something called the
dumb singularity
where the machine decides on a goal and
then just continues to improve towards
that goal but the
it just ends up like wiping out life
accidentally in the process
like it just decides in silence We're
Not Gonna know yeah it just decides that
uh everything needs to be the color
black so so mine's the entire Earth in
order to produce uh 400 trillion gallons
of paint and then just covers everything
in it extincting all life in the
processing the what you brought up
before that wonderful statement just
makes me think yeah it's like a very
quantitative kind of analysis right
graphs charts statistics it's very
quantitative ignoring qualitative
entirely which is like if you get into a
social science or Humanities education
right you're taught the difference
between quantitative and qualitative
research
but this is probably what billionaires
like billionaires are bored because
they're already billionaires like
there's nothing to do except become more
of a billionaire and then it's like the
pr they're still alienated from life
that the only purpose they can conceive
of themselves as having is to extend
life indefinitely so it's PR they're
like mythology it's the mythology of an
investment opportunity for board
billionaires it's kind of it's actually
yeah this actually kind of makes sense
of why they are in or some of them are
interested in Renee Gerard's ideas
because
memetic desire
if you have the means to get everything
and you're kind of obsessed with and you
You observe desires of humanity and
you're able to fulfill them all memetic
desire by the way is seems to be what
Lacon means when he says like the like
desires the others desire
yeah yeah that like desires desire of
the other it's essentially just an
argument about how all of our desires
for things we we tend to mimic and and
fall into
um I think when we see like models of
how objects are endowed with value by
other people we end up buying into those
models of what makes something valuable
and so we are mimicking the desire of
others
um so I guess I could see from the
perspective of being some Silicon Valley
billionaire or millionaire
um how this Insight could be repackaged
as some kind of a self-help agenda at
least the very least you could probably
see how and like marginalizing those
questions about social and economic
inequality and the qualitative
questions about experiences of
difference and and and marginality
you know it just then papers over those
problems by saying but look what this
like great future is going to offer us
and like all that'll just disappear like
by Fiat we can just ignore like the
central questions about democracy and
Marxism and emancipation
we can just ignore those because look
where we're headed somewhere great so
just don't worry right like that's
that's idealism right it's like
it's a kind of hostility towards the
world because you just imagine that you
fantasize whatever there's some solution
to all these problems coming we
shouldn't let it get us down right no
mention of those sorts of things and
these thinkers because it's
just not because again it's like a I
mean it's just using old school terms
it's like a Bourgeois ideology I mean
they're super interesting questions
taken and taken out of context or taken
in isolation from the world they're
interesting questions
but I mean
then it's like okay so [ __ ] what
where we live forever and even if it is
right then there's the suggestion like
okay so now we're gonna need like an a
priesthood of Elites to manage this
technology and Dole it out care very
carefully to those who deserve it who
are who can be apostatized into their
Immortal race of New Gods right like
it's kind of reminds me of the
priesthood the atomic priesthoods that
they were talking about half a century
ago with managing nuclear technology
because it was such a big important
advancement and it's real
but then they fall quickly into this
sort of like
the class antagonism just gets
completely
papered over with these idealistic
assumptions yeah I mean I think that I'm
I certainly agree with both of you on
the religious aspect
um of how a lot of this comes across
I myself will say that I have
you know maybe as a child who grew up
watching Star Trek the Next Generation I
I I wish I don't think it's inevitable
but I do wish for a world where we have
or somehow crack the code to be able to
you know have
harness virtually unlimited energy to be
able to one day maybe have you know as
they say full service automated luxury
communism
um that would be nice I don't think it's
in any means inevitable but I think it
would be cool
um
and it seems like hypothetically
possible in the sense that we have this
giant GL ball of Fusion Energy in the
sky that you know if you could somehow
harness it
um you know and redirect it you would
have basically
virtually unlimited energy
but there is certainly like I think I am
a little bit
as the kids say black pilled on the
possibilities for human moral
development
and you know when we talk about you know
we Pat like Humanity Pats itself on the
back for abolishing slavery and you know
giving women the right to vote and
participate in society but I do think
that there's reasons to think that none
of those things would have would have
happened if it wasn't for some
technological development like people
didn't do that because they're better
human beings people did that because it
was it became possible to to have
industrial production and and women were
able to have birth control pills and all
those things were I think crucial to
make those conditions possible it's a
it's a new means of production it's
going to have owners it's going to have
economic uses it's going to create a
different kind of social field is
probably going to emanate from it at
different kinds of relations of
production which is what we were
worrying about last week is our own
position within the relations of
production that chat AI is going to
alter
right but that's you know those are the
conditions not the after effects
as much right I mean it's just a it's a
conflicting table of values because if
you if you if you look at charts of
certain material uh effects or causes
yeah of course we're less likely to die
from disease that's awesome I'm pretty
sure an AI wrote the vaccine for the
modern effects seen for covid
is that wow true I think it wrote it in
like I don't know it wrote in like two
days basically
which is awesome that's that's cool but
no matter how much you talk about
improved uh material conditions or less
dying of of random causes or or anything
like that you go fine but there's
nothing they have no part of their
philosophy is really about the value the
valuable things in experience like to
stay alive for what
yeah that's a good point and I can say
if you gave me the option to live
forever and said here you can do this I
would click no 100 of the time I think
that would be terrible and terrifying
I'm trying to get through whatever 70
years I might have I mean if I if I
could have the option to live forever
but I wouldn't be immortal so I could
just like kill myself when I got tired
of it I I would take that
I wouldn't want to be forced to be
immortal though like I wouldn't want to
be forced so that like I'm gonna live
forever no matter you don't have a
choice no they're not gonna let your
generation they're not gonna let you die
they need slay they're gonna need slaves
you are going to be forced to exist just
to do everything that they don't want to
do and on the same on that same point
it's no surprise that the philosophies
that they're interested in also include
like a really long form utilitarianism
like as long as I do more good in my
life in total then it doesn't matter
what I do now if I [ __ ] someone over in
the short term and they also have this
new thing with stoicism too and I don't
know if there's like a sophisticated
version of stoicism as opposed to the
version that they espouse which is just
indifference
is seen as virtue right or what about
what about ancient Greeks right they
didn't think slaves as humans so they
can they don't have to enjoy life
that that when they're working for
somebody else that's that's when they're
at their best
that kind of like
you know you can't just contain those
questions can't contain it all in
epistemology and allow neat common sense
to fill in the ethical gaps it doesn't
work that way it's a at least that's a
recipe for a kind of very disastrous
way of thinking that the transhumanists
like triumphantly adopt they love it
yeah their their new form of
utilitarianism I can't remember the name
of it's really pissing me off but it's
floating around Sam begman freed said he
was this kind of person but it's
something utilitarianism where you just
make
as much money as you can and then you
can like do good things with it after
it's like I I can change Humanity by
becoming wealthy I think Bill Gates
probably started this but it's the like
ends Justified it means so if I have to
[ __ ] someone over in the short run it's
okay because my my good deeds later will
cancel out my [ __ ] over people yeah
in the in the short term
which is so convenient for them as is
stoicism stoicism is just like the most
can be you can see directly in terms of
like a material conditions or class
analysis exactly why they drift towards
this stuff yeah and that's that's
exactly what idealism kind of is when on
this podcast you know we have like our
big anti-ideal idealism good or bad
discussions right like here's Carrie
Wolfe's quote for adorno when he talks
about idealism says it's a kind of
violence quote a violence and rage
against the materiality and
heterogeneity of the preponderance of
the object
whose non-identity indifference the
concept
of idealism and identity Theory attempts
to suppress and master and thought right
which is a kind another way of saying
yeah these problems will work themselves
out we don't need to think of the
objective conditions say like capitalism
introduces into our lives we don't
because they'll just be solved if we
come up with the right Solutions techno
optimism techno-humanism
transhumanism whatever yeah it's a it's
not a direct form of violence but it's a
very uh diffuse
aggressive it looks like
um on its face like no we're gonna
Retreat why don't you want the good
things for us of course we're just gonna
put our brains into computers and live
longer who wouldn't want that uh we'll
get it first of course but then you guys
will all get it later
but yeah I think you're right that it's
a very diffuse form of violence without
there's no critical reflection either
whatsoever like just the basic question
you want to live forever why there's no
answer to that it's like so I can spend
my
so I can spend my billion dollars that's
it yeah like commodity fetishism right
like the magic of the of AI is kind of
just not in question it's just accepted
it's fetishized it's you know
that old term that's brought in from
anthropology it kind of has a magical
power
and that's just then that that's where
ideology kind of starts right and it
covers over the real circumstances under
which it is being made and contested and
and deployed in an on a direly unequal
social fields and it's not going to help
us all right there's even with AI right
there's still the internet gaps that
exist in the world right what about
people who don't have internet coverage
right the the the internet Gap thing
like I mean there's just so many
so many factors that this kind of
stylized sexy philosophy just kind of
and that's why the violence against
material
comes in we have to do it because we
can't we can and yeah of course I'm
excited to see this I'm excited that AI
is something that I can have a
conversation with and and that that's
that is very cool stuff but exactly
still gotta eat [ __ ] and [ __ ] at the end
of the day
yeah exactly that I mean that's the
nuanced view
um and I think you're right like but I
agree with both of you that it's
in the tech world it's kind of taken up
uh uncritically but I I also think it's
worth
it's worth pointing out that that I do
think
sometimes this critique of
techno-utopianism and techno optimism
ignores the
the level at which I feel like our
society right now is in a very
pessimistic era
so yes like it almost I think it almost
portrays or like over portrays the level
to which society actually feels
optimistic about this stuff
in my maybe because I'm in an academic
bubble of some kind on Twitter to some
extent and obviously in my own life
um but it strikes me that the kind of
critical attitude you know even going
back to our early up or one of our
earliest episodes where we talked about
Bruno LaTour and talking about how it
has critique lost its Steam I think this
drive to constantly problematize every
new thing and talk about the
implications and be like well who's
gonna own the algorithm and are the
algorithms going to be used by
corporations and well and like yeah
those are all legitimate questions
um
but sometimes I feel like that amount of
critique where you're constantly
problematizing at the expense of what
pills just said before which is like
this is [ __ ] cool like this is really
[ __ ] cool and it's like sometimes
that Perpetual critical attitude
prevents us from just acknowledging what
is obviously just like a really [ __ ]
cool thing that doesn't mean that you're
you aren't critical I think it's about
taking that's what that's what it means
to be a careful thinker is to be able to
hold two things in your mind at the same
time and I think like you can do that
you're right I mean
you're right that it's to just be
critical and to say you know who's going
to own this and what's gonna have I
think that's like that's always going to
happen with any new technology they're
gonna Own It someone's gonna own it it
won't be me and I don't really give a
[ __ ] about criticizing it on those
grounds what I think needs to be
criticized though is that they are both
inventing the stuff and then deciding on
the meaning of stuff and the thing that
I object to is the mythology that they
put in the stuff that is coming out at
the same time as
as inventing it and in that mythology
the world is only getting better when I
think it's just a bare fact it's obvious
to everyone who is not them that our
lives are already worse than our parents
and that Trend doesn't seem to be
there's no there's no plan to reverse
that Trend either that's why I agree
we do have to remind the critical
theorists to enjoy life no totally I I
don't I don't think that I'm I don't
think that I'm meant to imply that
either of you I see either of you as
like fitting into this kind of Perpetual
critical attitude more just a broader
observation
that I do think that that techno-utopian
attitude
um is pretty minority
um I I don't I don't think that even
outside of Academia to me at least
anecdotally it doesn't feel like people
are that optimistic
about how amazing it is
optimism sold a lot of [ __ ] crypto
yeah that or that hope you hope for
optimism you know like the whole
question of like having to prop up these
markets with just saying good things
about it is also a horrible question but
I I know I think I get I know what
you're getting at right like the
critique running out of steam
I mean it's like making sure that our
whatever questions our credit our
objects of criticism our doubt are
genuine and real and not arbitrary and
fake and flimsy it's like is it
Cartesian doubt where it's just kind of
arbitrarily doubting everything asking
questions about things that like is the
floor gonna be there when I get out of
bed in the morning that's a stupid
stupid question but then real genuine
doubt that like I think Charles purse
emphasizes more not these paper doubts
if I write it down on paper thus I doubt
it like no that's not how doubt works
right it's got to be real and genuine
and just like you right you you conform
to a certain kind of skepticism right
that that you would feel yes includes
these issues too and it's about you know
the real it's about the the efficacy of
doubting I guess that again maybe the
pragmatists the consequences the the
effects rather than just the Dow in fact
sake which you know the liberal end of
the he's right to question you know what
critical theory being taught in the
University today is a way of just
arbitrarily doubting everything it's
kind of the doubt industry that that
seems to comfortably Rush shoulders with
the this this stem wet dream industry
yeah totally and I and I also think one
of the things that bothers me about it
is just that it's these doubts this
constant doubting and critiquing is
premised on I think
this idea that there are all these
people out there who like really buy
into this and that's the hegemony is
like oh like Society is ruled by I'm
like I don't really think that that's
true like no one's optimistic about
anything anymore I like who are these
people who think that these things are
going to solve all our problems like
there's a few of them but I just don't
think anyone really believes that I was
reminded of you know in the 50s and 60s
you would see these advertisements for
like refrigerators on TV and they would
say things like the Miracles of science
right and it's like like how cringe
would that be today for somebody to
actually like appeal to the miracle like
no one would [ __ ] say that anymore
because no one believes in that kind of
simplistic like optimistic view of
science I mean the gendered universe of
the domestic technology advertisements
are so are so cringy and hilarious today
yeah absolutely well now how cringy is
Coke's new I've been seeing it at the
World Cup Coke's new thing is uh their
slogan is real Magic
so we've moved past we've moved past
science to just again believing in uh
Magic we gotta refetishize the commodity
like literally haven't seen I haven't
watched a single second of the World Cup
so I have no idea what you're talking
about like Coca-Cola advertisements are
the worst for that oh my God they jumped
in on like um the protests and like
I showed like a someone giving a
Coca-Cola that was Pepsi to be fair that
was Pepsi that was Pepsi and that was a
real fail that was a flop of an
advertisement yeah it was but Coke does
have a cola what was this their old
slogan that zijak liked it's like the
real thing or the yeah something like
that it was like Coca-Cola like the real
thing and the real one yeah like don't
don't substitute for any fakes but like
what the f what the [ __ ] is fake magic
how do you have real magic as opposed to
fake magic yeah I don't I don't know
it's pretty funny I was meant I meant to
ask I mean I know we should wrap up but
um
I would I thought it could be fun
um since our last episode to share any
like cool findings with the AI chatbot
what kind of experiments have you two
done anything worth talking about or not
really I did some experimenting with it
like um
I would I would agree to grade something
and then I would put it into the AI to
see if it agreed with my my grading and
it was pretty it was pretty close
sometimes and sometimes it like you just
cannot specify what factors it needs to
assess and so it's really really hard to
use it as a creating tool unfortunately
yeah
the one thing I kept trying to get it to
do was to write in the style of guitari
um and of course it could not
it didn't even want it didn't even want
to try but I kept I did it in so many
different ways because I was like this
would be a bit because the guitar is the
the weirdest writer it couldn't do it
yeah I think there's big gaps in what
it's been trained on so I mean those
questions will have to wait it's
probably just got like Reddit our
philosophy in there and that's it yeah
it also said guitari wrote uh simulacra
and simulation so I don't I don't know
yes I don't know what kind of video
training data it gets
it gets weird things wrong for sure so
like like that's the easiest thing to
check right anyway what have you used it
for I've experimented with it lots of
different things like Eric I I tried to
see what it would do when I copy and
pasted assignments what kind of a kind
of critical evaluation would it give and
my experience was similar it's not
really worth the risk of using it to
grade because it does make some weird
mistakes sometimes but it also makes
it's just hard to predict
um uh to to know whether it's actually
but when it does a good job it's good I
mean it it says more things than I would
say because I'm lazy so what it does
really well that I don't do very well
when I'm giving feedback is it's set
it's it opens with a really positive
remark
it'll say like what the thing does well
and I tend to just skip that and go
right to how the student [ __ ] up
that's nice you can write your positive
remarks for you that would be uh time
saving exactly but I also okay the most
the funniest thing I got it to do was to
have a conversation with me where I was
pretending to be a therapist
in the style of Carl Rogers humanist
approach and it was a bit contorted
because you had to continue to be like
okay give me a hypothetical response as
my therapist and then like you have to
frame it and then it'll give a response
um and then it'll explain why it gave
that response it would be like I would
say this because it would make the
patient feel more secure about this and
this and this
and then I would be like and then you
have to tell it like ask me a follow-up
as this and
you know it was not
very deep
in what it was asking and I'm sure you
know someone really trained in that
method would be like this is complete
[ __ ] but it was cool that it was
actually able to keep up the
conversation uh in that way
and if you I don't know if you've tried
this too you can just tell it be like
ask me a question and it'll it'll it'll
it'll engage and um
yeah it'll engage in a conversation with
you and ask you stuff and then ask you
follow-ups based on how you respond so
in a way it just creates more work for
us which which puts me in mind of my
closing thoughts which are that I
remember we were doing the the um the
Cyber sin project stuff and I had my
mind was full of Stafford beer and he
was talking about the way we introduce
computers into society
is supposed to be to solve our problems
and make things easier but we do not do
it that way we when we introduce
computers it tends to make things harder
and much less efficient than things that
were already being done much more
efficiently
and I was look at Marx's chapter on
machines and capital and he says you
know you'd think that the introduction
of machines into Manufacturing in the
transition into full-scale industrial
production would have made less work but
it actually deepened the wage slavery
and servitude and made the work much
more intense
made the exploitation occur at a much
higher rate than in handicraft
manufacturing style when things were
still kind of subjectively working first
then you have this this objective
organization Guided by machines which
humans become the appendages of and so
AI is just going to deepen that and and
with Stafford beers kind of more
technocratic take it's going to make
things harder not easier for us because
we're just going to be combing through
[ __ ] to work out the mistakes
instead of just doing the [ __ ] work
ourselves the first time
exactly we still keep these idealist
dreams that once it's been trained on
the right content then none of those
problems will be there anymore so let's
just eat [ __ ] until then okay great well
there will be there will be a new form
of I want to call it literacy it won't
be actual literacy but it'll be a new
form of uh literacy in in terms of like
getting the right output from an AI like
what you're actually kind of looking for
that'll be a new skill yes exactly I
totally agree with that
um skills I told one of the things I
said to this administrative person and
Professor who are asking about the
implications for the University I I said
like this is something that is going to
make it so that's a lot of undergrads
could just not bother learning how to be
a good writer
and get by yeah but we don't need to be
good writers but you have to be good at
but if you want to get A's you have to
understand what you still have to be a
good writer because you have to be able
to recognize is that output actually
right so you'd actually you'd have to
actually know the content in order to
it's like kind of like uh
using calc people I wonder if people
were like decrying the death of math
education when calculators came out
but it just develops a new skill they
changed the format of testing so you
know you have to show your work rather
than
get the right answer so maybe that maybe
something like that happens exactly
exactly
yeah with phones and social media
they're reading and writing more than
ever before they're just not doing it in
the way we want them to be so we
consider it illiteracy it's a like look
at our distinctions again um
it's they're not good but I mean this is
all folded into a big history of
Information Technology right scroll to
the Codex codex to the printed book
analog storage to digital storage now ai
retrieval tools like it's just you know
I want to see a
I want to see a transhumanist rate that
[ __ ] history and pay attention to the
changing modes of production of
knowledge production instead of just
trumpeting the potential benefits
of long life and and
AI slaves
there's a there's a technological
post-humanist point in there in their
Victor with each there's an oral mind
and then an alphabetic mind and then a a
book mind and now whatever uh the
computer a social media smartphone mind
it's all
part of the apparatus the conceptual
Superstar so whatever whatever the AI
might if I don't know how much it's
going to be used but we'll we'll now be
moving into an AI an AI mind inside of
us not just inside the uh machine just
count on things getting stupider and and
easier both stupider and easier
yes exactly will there will be a new
um phenomenon which will be kind of
clear but stupid right will be the new
Norm whereas before but which is kind of
nice because it was really annoying to
deal with unclear yeah yeah it's like
clear but stupid like analytic
philosophy I know you I I know you can
do it but why would you
I don't endorse that statement but yes I
guess the the point remains that it will
still be commodifying our data and doing
all that
classic [ __ ] we discussed on the
Techno feudalism episode
just with it like the the emergent mode
of production I guess interacting with
the dominant capitalist mode that's
what's good
What If instead of at Mass advertising
every single ad was like
built by an AI on the spot just for you
like do you think advertising would work
on you at that point uh
one prediction that I guarantee you will
be true is that you'll get an ad written
by an AI That's only for you and each ad
will be done for sure it won't be
advertising campaigns
I mean I love the way Spotify Amazon
recommends products they think I might
be interested based on my history I mean
but they're always terrible just like oh
you bought a chair do you want another
chair no you [ __ ] idiot I already
bought that that's why I don't need it
anymore
That's my kind of shopping I feel that
advertising doesn't work on me
there be but I want it to
like like I want an ad to actually show
me something that I want yeah so if it
can do that sweet
show me something that I actually want
the old dictum I know it doesn't work
but anyway no no but that's the thing
it's like I'm not claiming that it
doesn't work on me because
like
my self-experience of being a consumer
I'm one of those people who obsessively
does research and read reviews before I
buy anything that I want
so I so if I see something that's
advertised to me
uh that I don't know that I want
it always ends up going through that
process of kind of Investigation
but I would be very impressed if if
somehow an AI could learn that that's
what I do and would only give me things
that it would somehow know would pass my
smell test
you know what companies are going to use
this AI for is it going to be to pretend
to be people on the internet
and develop entire profiles of people
and then they will be the ones
recommending their own products to you
it'll be you'll go to Reddit and you'll
be like for Target this is the greatest
this is the greatest gamer chair I've
ever bought and it's actually just a
piece of [ __ ] because a bot is writing
it to you
that's true that's a risk right that's a
risk so that's why you have to go to
suspicious about reviews
yeah well that's why you read lots of
reviews and you you look for
inconsistencies yeah we'll have to look
at what other people's personal ad Bots
are recommending to them and be like I
think mine's broken
it keeps telling me to have these these
Greens Plus supplements I don't want
them like like I just had to buy a new
beer trimmer because mine old one died
and I spent I probably spent a couple
hours looking into what the best option
is
but if some advertising bot could just
save that time for me and tell me this
is what you're gonna want that would be
great and it is great by the way after
spending that time I got it it's awesome
it's the
hey
unless maybe it wants to sponsor this
podcast we're not advertising for free
yeah we did advertise really like it we
did advertise the days for a few
episodes yeah we did yeah we should be
more practical with it like if it could
uh tell me when I should vote Yes on
strike mandates and write our demands
for us using like Quantified like what
we could get out of our employers like
then yeah it can write our bargaining uh
statements interesting tell us when to
strike tell us when our bosses are gonna
dock our pay by like uh cutting off
print privileges or something and
indirectly give us pay cuts and it'll
warn us about them and say this is what
you have to do now contact these people
get a strike going and reverse that
[ __ ] immediately and why stop there
you could also just have like an AI you
input your preferences and then it can
go out and do all the votes for you you
can you don't have to be a real
Democratic subject a responsible
Democratic subject anymore just say I
prefer the left or left leaning option
of any choice so just pick go find all
the candidates platforms and pick that
yeah yeah find me who to vote for tell
me when the revolution's coming give me
a give me an idea of what my best next
investment is
chat GPT how do you plan a successful
Revolution just go through all the ones
that have worked in the past and how
they maintained why don't I ask it and
then we'll end with that response
okay how do I plan look at the Cyber sin
project have worked better how could
they have maintained those how do I plan
a successful Revolution
maintain the game baby how did cyber sin
go wrong
okay so it's oh it's giving me some
interesting stuff here oh wow it's
giving me a list of steps okay wow it's
actually like
that's funny
um okay it's a successful it's still
writing but I'll start reading a
successful a successful Revolution is
not just about overthrowing a government
or regime but also about implementing a
new system that is fair just and
sustainable to plan a successful
Revolution here are some steps to
consider one identify the root cause of
the current situation that needs to be
changed this could be political economic
social or environmental issues two build
a coalition of people who share the same
vision and goals for the revolution this
could include various groups
organizations and individuals who are
willing to work together towards a
common cause three develop a clear and
detailed plan that outlines the specific
step strategies and tactics that will be
used to achieve the desired outcome this
could include the roles and
responsibilities of each member of the
Coalition as well as the resources uh
and support that will be needed four
communicate the plan to the broader
public to gain their support this can
involve organizing public meetings
rallies or other events to raise
awareness and generate support for the
revolution
five be prepared for potential
challenges and setbacks this could
include resistance from the current
government and its supporters as well as
potential violence and conflict it is
important it is important to have
contingency plans in place and to be
prepared for any eventuality and finally
six After the revolution is successful
work towards implementing the new system
and addressing the issues that led uh to
the need for change this could involve
creating new policies laws and systems
that are fair and just and addressing
the needs and concerns of the people
there you have it
an area an AI generated plan for
revolution
final step is the great Terror who
didn't mention that
well in the books I'll see you guys on
the barricades thank you everybody yep
yeah
so practical I love it
[Music]